my hair is kind of crazy but a lot of
you guys
have been asking questions so i kind of
ended up being like a full-time
tick-tock like youtuber by accident like
i honestly did not mean to end up here
like
seriously because about a year and a
half ago
i was working this sales job and it was
literally like
the worst sales job of my life like i
hated it i hated it so much but
i kept hearing that if you make it past
your first year in sales like
you're going to make a lot of money
you're going to love it it just sucks
the first year
i'm like a year in and i realize i still
hate my life like i hate my life so much
so what i ended up doing
was i decided to make a plan i'm like
okay how can i get out of here i started
researching like different
programs to like go back to school for
like media or like video
something like that i end up posting on
tic tac and my tic tac accounts like
starting to get a couple thousand
followers
nothing crazy but i think i was at like
maybe like 50k
75k so i found this program where i
could go to england it was gonna be so
sick
and i could play basketball while
getting a degree a master's degree in a
year
and then i figured i could like work on
my youtube and my tic toc on the side
and initially i was supposed to go in
september
but and like that was going to be about
a year of my sales job and i was like
okay i can leave
but then then it got even worse because
they pushed it off to
january so in about october i'm like
okay
season's gonna start in january i'm
gonna quit my job
and things are gonna be cool i'm gonna
quit my job like october
give me a couple months to spend with
the family and then you know you're
going to go to england you're going to
play basketball it's going to be so fun
you have three months to like start your
tick tock and your youtube channel
no no they do me so dirty
then the season gets cancelled again so
i'm just like kind of left like with no
job
no real plan and just like because now
season's in september and it's like i
don't even know what i'm gonna do next
but i take my life day by day
but i will say this i'm so much happier
now than i was
in that shitty sales job i hated that
sales job so
i'm gonna take you guys with me you'll
see what happens